President Trump is standing firm after a
tidal wave of criticism following his
summit with russia's President Vladimir
Putin his strongest critics called his
remarks treasonous the president stood
next to Putin and seemed to accept his
denial that Russia interfered in the
2016 presidential election downplaying
US intelligence assessments that show
Russia Russia was involved on his way
home from the summit the president
tweeted this I have great confidence in
my intelligence people but he also
continued to praise Putin the men others
called an enemy of the United States
which are Jang travelled back from
Helsinki with the president she was on
board Air Force One we should good
morning to you a good morning Gail and
to everybody senior administration
officials tell CBS News there is an
effort underway to clean up the mess
created by President Trump's comments
yesterday officials want him to say he
believes US intelligence / Putin and to
make clear there will not be any effort
on the part of the u.s. to cooperate
with Russia on the Millar probe he said
what a shame he felt it was very hard
for me to make a deal because of you
know all of this nonsense
president Trump blamed the Russia
investigation for deteriorating
us-russia relations and last night
continued his praise of the Russian
president I thought that President Putin
was very very strong earlier the
president cited with Vladimir Putin over
his own US intelligence agencies which
have concluded the Russian government
interfered in the election I have great
confidence in my intelligence people but
I will tell you that President Putin was
extremely strong and powerful in his
denial today Friday Special Counsel
Robert Muller announced an indictment
against 12 Russian intelligence agents
for interfering in the election may I
give this to you to look at sir during
an interview with chris wallace putin
refused to look at the special counsels
indictment against his agents russia as
a state has never interfered with the
internal affairs of the united states
the president also seemed open to
putin's offer to have russian
intelligence
assist in the case he offered to have
the people working on the case come and
work with their investigators with
respect to the 12 people I think that's
an incredible offer and seem to laugh
off a question about having compromising
information on president Trump they have
no information on Trump one thing you
know if they had it they would have been
out after President Trump sided with
Putin over his own Director of National
Intelligence dan coates coach shot back
yesterday in a statement saying the
intelligence community has been clear
about Russia's meddling in the election
and its ongoing effort to undermine our
democracy despite everything a White
House official tells CBS News the
president feels very good after the
summit bianna this as the White House is
in damage control this morning we
judging thank you